- I wanna welcome everybody.
My name is Paul North.
I'm a professor in the
German Department at Yale
and this is the first
in a series of workshops
that carries the title "The
Value of Marx's Capital."
Obviously a little play on words there.
I wanna start each of these episodes
with a quote from the author
who has been kind enough
to come to our screens.
And this is a quote from Terrell
Carver who's with us today.
It goes like this, quote,
"No one who wants to
read a work of history,
even a history of capitalism,
will find this book easy to understand."
He's referring to Marx's "Capital."
"But then," he adds,
"capitalism is not an
easy phenomenon to grasp
or an easy one to live through."
I want to recognize a
whole bunch of people
as we're starting.
First, the director of the
Whitney Humanities Center,
Alice Kaplan,
for being kind enough to
let us try this experiment
in the middle of a pandemic.
I want to thank Sandra Malan-Bowles
for her incredible organizational skills,
and Leana Hirschfeld-Kroen
who is the graduate student
that has pulled this all together.
I want to thank also Yasmin
who is going to handle
the technical parts here.
This is a set of workshops that
run in tandem with a seminar
in which there are about 25 undergraduates
who are reading through Marx's
"Capital" very carefully.
So I want to welcome the
students in the seminar.
And then I'd like to
thank the Franke family
for making possible these lectures,
the Franke Lectures in the Humanities,
that is Richard and Barbara Franke,
who gave this money to
present important topics
in the humanities to a
wide and general audience.
One of the reasons we're
doing this is because
I am involved in a project to edit
a new translation into English
of Marx's "Capital, Volume I"
and I have to thank my
collaborator for that,
Paul Reitter of OSU whom I
want to introduce to you now.
I'm not sure you'll be able to see him
but he will come in later
when it's question time.
Paul Reitter is a translator of some note,
also a scholar of German studies,
and he is rendering "Capital,
Volume I" into an English
that you can understand
and that will also delight you.
This volume should come out
with Princeton University Press
in 2022 we hope.
Now it's a great pleasure
to introduce Terrell Carver,
who is a professor of Political Theory
in the School of Sociology, Politics,
and International Studies
at the University of Bristol in the UK.
Terrell Carver has been a visiting fellow
at the Research School of Social Sciences
of the Australian National University,
at the Center for Asian
and Pacific Studies
at Seikei University in Tokyo.
He has been visiting
professor in the States
and many other times in
Australia, in the Far East.
Most notable for our interests
is that he was a member of
the Editorial Commission on
the German Marx-Engels Edition,
the Marx-Engels-Gesamtausgabe,
otherwise known as the MEGA,
which is the most significant event
in the textual fund of Marxian writings
ever it seems to me.
Terrell Carver specializes
in Marx, Engels, and Marxism
and on the philosophy and
methodology of social science.
He has written widely on political theory
but has a big bookshelf
on Marx and Engels.
Specifically, he wrote the book on Marx
or a book on Marx, that is "Marx"
in Polity Press from 2018.
There are many books on Marx
but there are very few books on Engels
and Terrell Carver, I think
you would have to admit
is the world expert on Engels.
He wrote the book many years ago now
but it's still a very important book,
"Marx and Engels: The
Intellectual Relationship."
There is no Marx without Engels
as I'm sure Terrell would agree.
This book is from 1984.
He wrote "The Life and
Thought of Friedrich Engels"
which came out in 1990
and was reissued this year,
and was a co-editor on
"Engels Before Marx"
which is a very important
book to understand
where Engels came from.
I'd like to give the microphone
over to Professor Carver
but first I want to thank him for a book
that was important for me.
That's "The Postmodern Marx"
which came out in 1998.
That's the first book that made me think
I wanted to read "Marx."
So thank you and welcome.
- Well, I'm delighted
and honored to be here
and really pleased to
hear that comment about
that particular book.
I wish you'd been a reviewer
but we'll get on with the
plot here this evening.
I'm also delighted to
hear that it's a workshop,
so I expect to work out
and I expect the audience to work too.
I think there are lots of you
and I'm sorry, I can't see everybody
and interact in that way,
but we'll do what we can with this medium.
Thanks, particularly to Leana and Yasmin
for helping me along through some of this,
and I'm still tackling the
Yale forms as we speak.
But everybody's very patient.
Just a little bit of background.
I've been in the UK for quite a long time
but I am actually originally American.
So I'm just mentioning that
so that we don't feel the need
for a lot of intercultural
translation exercises.
I actually graduated
from Columbia in 1968.
I went to high school
with a flag out the front
and took the SATs,
and did all of that.
So, I'm not a visitor who
sort of dropped in from Mars
although Paul North did
say that with this on
I look like a helicopter pilot.
So, I thought we'd shut up and get going
with a few slides just
as a kind of warm up.
So I'll see if I can share the screen here
and set up PowerPoint
which just looks like it's
actually working right now.
So I've called this talk
"Das Kapital Critique,
History, and Knowledge"
and I'll explain why I've called it that.
And this is a bit of framing exercise
that sets up philosophy and methodology
so that what I say about
capital, the text and about Marx
makes some kind of sense.
Perhaps as a bit of a
health warning in the fit,
you probably won't get
this kind of outlook
or this kind of approach
from the other speakers
in the series, most of whom I know,
and some are quite close colleagues,
but I hope it's refreshing.
And there's a bit of a
methodological angle,
I'm kind of inclined
so Paul North will know
from "The Postmodern Marx"
to take an idea and
put it out very clearly
of what some people
consider to be an extreme
and unsettling form
of just to see how much
mileage there is in the idea
and what kind of pushback there is on it.
So, there should be some
lively debate this evening.
So if I can change the slide.
There we are.
I think it's quite important
in these exercises,
whether literary or political theory,
to get visually acquainted with who it is
that we're making speak to us
or imagining talking
to us through the text.
So, here we have two images of Marx.
These are actually the first
images after the early 1840s,
the early photographs.
The one on the left 1861
and the one on the right 1867.
Just the year that
"Capital" is published for the first time.
So changing the slide.
This is the way I like
to think about Marx.
This is him in his university uniform
as a Prussian student.
He's about 22.
And he's just on the term
of leaving university,
getting his PhD by post
which is a great idea.
And leaving academia forever.
And it's quite important to understand
how repressive, reactionary,
neo-feudal, no nothing
the German kingdom states, principalities
disunited as they were into 40 odd units,
plus the Austrian empire.
How reactionary unmodern this was
in terms of being repressive
and this apply to the university.
So his main tutor was chased
out of the university.
Karl knew that he was never
gonna get a university job
and he gave up on that pretty quickly.
So, the book on the left is the sort of
volcanic one of 2018
that Paul North was talking about.
And the first chapter is
called "Making Marx Marx."
There are two things going on here,
it's a kind of double (indistinct) really.
That is we have him here as a student
about to take a great turn in his life,
embark on making himself himself.
But the himself as he made himself
isn't really the same guy that he became
in what we call his reception
or how he was constructed and written up
for the history books and for the record.
So that latter story starts
in the very early 1870s
and it's quite difficult
to explain to people now
how obscure he was, how unfamous he was,
how there were lots of other guys around
who didn't appear to
be that much different.
Most of the memoir of this we
have date from 40 years later.
So people constructed
an idea after the fact
about what he was like.
And then we can project
that back into the letters
and other things that we have
are actually contemporary
with this process.
But methodologically I'm quite
keen to unpick and unpack
that kind of enterprise.
So in the early 1870s he
was constructed as a guru
and in a sense, a kind of founding father
of German socialism.
Right at the moment just
after the introduction
of the imperial constitution in 1871
when really for the first time,
at least a few people
could vote for something
that might make some difference,
although in practice,
probably not very much.
Again, it's a battle historically
to try to explain to people
how deeply undemocratic.
Even the constitutional
regimes of the times
actually where universal manhood suffrage
didn't hit the United Kingdom
'til the 1880s for instance,
and here we are only in the
early 1870s in the Reich.
So, at this point,
the two branches of the socialist movement
are getting together to unite.
One had been led by Ferdinand Lassalle.
He was rather conveniently dead
and it's quite easy to honor
people when they're dead
and they don't get in the way anymore.
And those who had Marx as
a mentor by correspondence
'cause of course he was living in London,
and he visited him from time to time
and were younger.
Thought that their
grouping within socialism,
their proto-political party
should have honorary founders
to rival the Ferdinand Lassalle
who was really quite famous
in the German states at the time
which Marx was not.
He had a certain notoriety as a 48er
who'd gone into exile because
he was prosecuted for treason.
But that was about it.
So at that point, Marx and Engels
were created and constructed
as important thinkers.
And at the time that was done,
not with "Das Kapital"
which was recently published
but with "The Communist
Manifesto" of 1848.
Marx and Engels were quite puzzled by this
and a bit standoffish.
And so, sort of wrote saying
that thing is 25 years old.
Nobody's read it since,
we've really pretty much forgotten it.
It does get one footnote in
"Das Kapital" interestingly,
but nobody in 1867 could
have got hold of a copy.
Most of the copies have been
seized by the Prussian police.
It was really a rare pamphlet.
So they said, why on earth
don't you write your own?
Which is one for now,
which is quite a reasonable
political question.
However, they were persuaded
to go along with this
process of constructing icons
and being made into symbols,
and gurus who would have works
which were then republished
through the later 1870s, 1880s,
and this is part of the
political story of socialism
as an intellectual movement.
So if we go right back to the beginning,
what actually happens with young Karl here
as he's about to leave university
and can't get an academic job?
Where exactly does he go?
He goes to a newspaper
office that is in Cologne,
not that far up the river.
A group of businessmen and
some French intellectuals
of the sort who are dedicated
to popular sovereignty,
liberalism, tinges of socialism
derived from French thinking.
There are little collective who want
to gather newspaper together.
This is actually quite difficult
and he becomes an associates,
and he tells us in his own
autobiographical sketch of 1859
that it's in this office
where he first made contact
with what he calls, quote,
"material interests," unquote.
Well, this is a well-known
biographical fact
but I've chosen in chapter one
in this book to pause on that
and try to think it
through quite carefully.
So, here we've got a university student
from a professional
intellectual background
in Trier, provincial backwater.
Comes to Cologne where
some enterprising types
are dedicating themselves to
politics, trade, and commerce.
This is quite a big
jump for an intellectual
and Marx clearly found
it really stimulating.
In other words, from his
education and philosophy,
history and jurisprudence,
he had learned really nothing
about trade, commerce,
and what industry might
be like given that in
the German states there
really was hardly any,
and then tucked away in
rather nasty little pockets.
So in this office,
we don't know very much
about what happened.
So not very much of this gets written
into the historical record.
We know who the businessmen were,
who were the backers of the paper
and who were, would be editors.
We know whom they wanted to
be editor which wasn't Marx,
it was actually Friedrich List
the becoming famous politically economist
in the German-speaking land.
So this was quite a new
kind of scientific subject
and it's important to
understand that in this kind of
neo-feudal reactionary order
making money through trade and
commerce was not very nice.
It wasn't something that
realists really very much wanted.
They wanted peasants with taxes
and so, have an easy
life and be landowners,
and not have modernizing change.
So within this reactionary regime
the press is strictly controlled as is
even conversation on subjects
that are taken to be political
which certainly includes anything to do
with religious doubt.
And the police are
around snooping on people
and giving them warnings
and all that kind of thing.
And of course, that had happened
to Marx's father in Trier.
So, these are not
inconsiderable kinds of things
to reckon with when you're
entering a newspaper office
and getting involved with people
who do believe in
liberalization to a point.
Believing in popular
sovereignty doesn't mean
that you believed even in
universal manhood suffrage,
far from it.
Most people who believed in
some version of popular sovereignty
certainly didn't think that
uneducated people should vote.
So the story of democracy
is not really about
the proclamation of votes for everybody.
The story of democracy
is really much more about
whom can we continue to exclude
whilst including a few more
than were there before.
So that's a bit of background
that this chapter actually sets off
and I think that should do
us a bit of an introduction
to how I conceive of Marx an author
and in particular as a political actor.
And so, I'll come on to that.
First of all, let's go
for some more visuals.
Here we have "Das
Kapital," the book itself.
Here's the first edition.
Again, I think it's quite
important in these things
to get some sense of
physicality in the original
so it is not a kind of disembodied text
that just exists in a logo world
as meanings and concepts.
It's actually a book written in German
for German-speaking audience.
That's what it looked like.
We know from the first
chapter where Marx mentions
his earlier so-called half
volume or first installment,
"Zur Kritik der Politischen Okonomie."
And that slat edition, that
little half volume of 1859.
Some of my Germanist friends
can help me out here.
I'm interested in their transition
from the Gothic typeface
to the Roman typeface.
I mean, they were both around,
I just wonder if anybody
thinks there's any particular
significance whether in
the place of publication
or the target audience.
I don't know.
Gothic typeface of course was around 'til
well into the 20th century
and my German course at Columbia,
we all learned to read that,
and I'm not sure that
undergraduates necessarily
do that anymore.
So here's a couple of things
for us to look at together
so in the mood and to
looking the right direction.
Part of this is to remind Anglophones
like ourselves in this gathering
that this is a German,
writing in German for a
German political audience.
Marx's political world
is really looking east.
He looks westward to France for culture,
for socialism, for communism,
for intellectual stimulation,
and for political economy
in the first instance.
So educated in the Rhineland
he was completely fluent in
French from an early age.
And if you're seeing the recent biopic
"Le jeune Marx" or "The Younger Marx,"
that's something they actually got right
in this German-Belgian co-production.
The characters in it
speak quite indifferently
to each other in German and French
as they go along with suitable subtitling.
So, we know that in learning French,
he also learned Roman style handwriting.
I did actually discover or track down
some previously unpublished
letters of his in London.
And when these kind of
fell out of a plastic bag
on someone's kitchen table,
I realized that I could
read his handwriting
quite easily on some.
And so I thought,
well, that's 'cause
he's writing in English,
but actually he learned
how to write cursive Roman
when as a school boy he learned French.
Otherwise he have the famously terrible
hand handwriting in German cursive Gothic
which is almost impossible to decipher
although, I mean, perhaps
some of my colleagues here
spend their time on
manuscripts from that era.
So that's a little bit
more of the background.
I'm fighting against the
idea in the Anglophone world
that having remove to
London at 1849, 1850,
and living there the rest of their lives
into the 1880s and 1890s,
Marx and Engels became honorary Englishmen
and speak to us in English.
And we now have 50 volumes of Marx
translated into English.
Engels is a completely
different case of course.
His English was very fluent
and he wrote and published
in it from a very early age,
barely 20, 21 years old,
because his dad took him
on business to England.
Marx's English was much more rudimentary
learned rather slowly.
He only got on with
reading English authors
as the 1840s progressed, 1845, six.
And his first visit to
England is an 1845 with Engels
to go to the library in Manchester.
His English was workable
and so he, for money, got
to write it quite fluently
in the 1850s and early 1860s.
But I think it's important to remember
that even in London,
his politics is pretty much lifting East
and so looking West to the US East Coast,
and so the Midwest to the German
speaking communities there,
and some of you will know
that some of his works
were actually published there
within that community.
So, a little bit of
philosophical backgrounds
just to set things up.
I've put critique down here
to say that this is not
just a method or a genre,
there it's that,
but for Marx it's actually an
ontology and an epistemology.
So this is where things get a bit
radical or extreme or,
I mean, Paul North will know this
from "The Postmodern Marx."
That is, it's an ontology and epistemology
that is what there is to know
and how we know it of
political intervention.
In communicative practice
and the communicative
practice is meaning-making
as a repetitious citational activity.
So that perhaps doesn't
mean a lot on its own
but as the discussion goes on,
I think it will become
a little bit clearer.
I put everything, I put history down to
put a few more things on the board.
That is to say within this ontology,
epistemology of meaning-making,
everything is historical.
Human history making is what there is
and historiography is what we say
about human history making
that we want to say.
And of course a lot is excluded
as we will know from discussions
about historiography.
And so, inclusion and exclusion from
about the last 40 years.
This is because everything
is communicative
if we want it to be communicative.
That is if we're making meanings,
we project those meanings outwards,
and then we read them
off as what the thing is
or what it is telling us.
Existence in a philosophical sense
is therefore meaningful
only within meaning.
It's not something outside of meaning
that is a validation point for meaning.
So some people will recognize this
and it may seem a bit heavy for an intro,
but I hope it'll pay off or
at least give you the idea
of how this is set up
and not perhaps what you ordinarily hear.
So within this,
knowledge is always and already purposive.
It's not abstract.
Nor is it unconnected
with political projects.
So one feature of capital of course
is to argue that political economy,
the economics of the time is not
a disinterested science done by scientists
who stand outside society
and outside politics.
It is rather itself a political project
and it says some things and
obfuscates or hides others.
So that's all entirely fair enough
and to be expected from
this point of view.
Science, therefore,
from Marxian perspective
and you can see this
in very early writings,
is technology,
is industry,
is commerce,
is capitalism.
So there's no kind of disinterested
zone of pure knowledge
and ask anybody who knows any scientist
where their money comes from.
And so, you can see that this is
an ongoing idea.
The working through of this perspective
in terms of Marx and his writings
and how they can be approached,
and I'm not saying this is the only way,
but just that it might be an
interesting and productive way,
and it does make a bit of
a change for most people.
This philosophical perspective
is worked out in a chapter in this book
which is published.
It's chapter 13 and the title is there,
"Socializing Knowledge
and Historicizing Society:
Marx and Engels and The
Manuscripts of 1845-46."
So, just to geek out on this,
the argument is put through
from the roughest pages
of the manuscripts that have gone into the
so-called German ideology,
it's the so-called book with
a so-called forever chapter.
This argument is actually fleshed out
from these very, very rough pages
which really are unique in the legacy
because they're the only
manuscript pages we've got
where Marx and Engels are actually
drafting things together.
And the only pages that we've got
where they're making extensive
rough draft corrections, crossing out,
changing one word literally into another,
and rephrasing things as they go along.
In those particular pages
which actually they excluded
from the things they were drafting,
I think probably on grounds
they were too theoretical.
These pages are interesting to us
and the object here is not to turn Marx
into a philosopher or an economist,
but rather to see what an interesting
view of society, knowledge, and history
arises through this method of critique.
And therefore, I think
you can see a vocabulary
kind of moving from one word, one phrase,
from one phrasing to another,
as that argument develops.
So, I'll leave the slides
at this particular point
and do a little bit of reading.
I did some pre-circulation
of something that I've written on capital
that's actually a 10,000 words.
It's still in draft.
It's going into something
that's written for historians.
It's called, Bloomsbury the publisher,
"History, Theory, and Method."
And it's written through
a kind of template.
So I'll read a few excerpts from that
to pick out some quotes
from this amazing book
so that we actually get
to hear some of Marx here
and not just to hear me.
But I thought it was quite unusual
and sort of puzzling choice
in saying this reference book chapter
is going to be for historians,
and is going to be about
Marx then choosing capital.
Because it's not considered
a work of history,
it doesn't fit historiography as a genre.
Marx isn't really rated as a
historian by historians mostly.
They've generally picked him apart
where they have taken the view
that he was doing history,
but doing it badly.
As I would say, he never
had an academic job,
didn't want to be an academic
historian or philosopher,
or an economist
so I was quite puzzled
that they chose capital
and also quite excited.
But it is quite a stretch for historians
as it is indeed for anybody
to pick up this book
and start on page one.
So quite a lot of this 10,000 words
is devoted to unraveling
the kind of puzzle that Paul
North gave me the intro.
That is how on earth do we
start reading this book?
And what do we make of it?
Well, this kind of takes
me back to the political
context of the time.
Virtually everything Marx published
as opposed to just wrote down
in notebooks or manuscripts,
had to get through a censor.
And quite a lot of his life
he was trying to get published
and dodged censors,
and had all his difficulties with that.
And indeed the newspaper
that he joined in 1842
was closed down by the censorship.
So this is an ongoing issue and a problem.
It follows that if he
wanted to say anything
much about politics other
than how good the rulers were,
you were going to be
scrutinized very heavily.
And the rigorous and the
religious establishment
were all entirely the same people.
So you criticize their religion,
you overthrow society,
you upset politics.
There's certainly no
division of anything there,
quite the opposite.
So they're always kind of sniffing along
on those lines as well.
"Capital" had to get
around the censor of like
all of Marx's works and indeed
those of his contemporaries,
the people he is associated
with and writing with.
They write it for publication
in a kind of code,
it's got to be coded as a philosophy
or eventually politically economy.
I think it's hard to
make people understand
that Marx writes about Hegel
not because he wants to
have a philosophical battle
with a dead philosopher,
but because Hegel is a political issue,
and Hegel is a political issue
because you can appear
to talk about philosophy
and actually in a coded way,
be talking about politics.
So you could get that kind
of thing through the censor
and through the academic authorities,
who of course made sure that
conservative professors were appointed
to give official lectures on Hegel
and the more radical commentary
comes in the alternative publications,
and that's the kind of
world that Marx grew up in
or got to know himself in the 1840s.
So we've got that first
difficulty with "Capital."
What kind of coding is it?
It's very ironic.
"Capital" itself is a satire.
He's setting the political
economist up for a fore.
He's fooling us really.
I mean, those of us in the know would know
that he's going to pull
the rug out from under them
and there is a critical work
in a very serious sense,
and it's not a minor criticism.
But to get this past the censor
and indeed to get a
gullible audience on board,
particularly among the
professors as he said,
it's got to look like a sober, serious,
a (speaks in foreign
language) scientific work
of political economy.
And indeed to a certain extent,
he thinks they were onto something
and got it right in certain respects
even if they didn't like the politics.
But they also got it wrong in a way
that he thinks is really interesting,
and that he can do things with.
So there's an element of parody here.
It's a very good parody.
It is a difficulty with parodies
that if they're too good,
the audience won't get
the satirical difference
between the parody satire
and the real thing.
So there are two reasons there
why it's coded as a parody.
One is to get it past the censor,
the other is to get an audience on board
and then whoops, pull the
rug out from under them
which he does very neatly
in the final chapters,
on part eight, chapters 26 to 33.
So, I really argue that for
all these reasons and others,
capitalism is a genre by itself.
It's not going to fit history
or sociology or philosophy.
You've got to kind of get
on board with the author
who's setting his own genre
and his own kind of context.
But he's in difficulties
trying to explain to you
particularly if you live 100,
60, 70, 80 years later.
That, I mean he's not gonna know that.
So there is that element of difficulty.
The political economy,
the economics of the times
is of course quite different
from modern economics.
And here, Marx got a kind of rug
pulled out from under himself.
In the later 1870s there
was what was called
the marginalist revolution in economics
and the economists were
pretty suddenly thrown over
as passe and unscientific,
not doing the right kind
of thing in the right way.
Obsessed with value
and with a kind of
philosophical moral problem,
which was where this profit come from.
Whereas in the marginalist world,
I mean, there really isn't
the problem about profit.
The only problem is really
how do people make more of it
and how to do that with
numbers and the empirical data,
roughly speaking.
And to move out of the
sphere of production
where Marx and the
political economists were
in the first instance into
the fear of consumption.
So modern marginalist
economics really starts
from the point of view
of the consumer with,
consumers with money in their
hands ready to buy things
and assume that that is
going to send a message
to producers via this mechanism.
So the whole thing is really turned
upside down and inside out.
And Marx I don't think ever,
ever realized that exactly.
It was just something,
it was really quite different
and from his perspective
didn't make any sense.
So trying to translate a
critique of political economy
to make it accessible for modern
readers is quite a stretch
so I congratulate the two
Pauls in taking this on.
It'll be fascinating to read the result.
So, I'm not quite sure
how I'm doing for time.
Paul North, can you
give me a clue on this?
- If you're feeling like
you're coming to an end,
there's probably a lot of questions.
- Okay.
- And you can fill in the details
in between people's questions.
So thank you for a great presentation
and especially for setting
"Capital" and "Marx"
into his context and its context.
That's something that really was forgotten
often in readings of "Capital."
I wanna give the first question
to my collaborator, Paul Reitter.
Go ahead, Paul.
- Thanks.
Terrell, it's great to meet you.
Thank you for the presentation.
We've actually been in
touch a little bit as well
over the summer and Terrell
is a translator of "Marx" too.
And so, when he talks about
the process of translating
"Marx" with an air of
sympathetic weariness or something,
you know where it comes from.
But he's produced some great translations
and I admire his translations
and I have read a bit about this argument
that "Capital" is, in a
fundamental way, a satire.
And I wanted to ask you about that
to follow up a little bit
because one thing that I've noticed
in doing the translation is that
when Marx translates passages
from political economy into German,
he engages in what you might call
a strongly domesticating
form of translation.
Meaning that he really
integrates their writing into his
so that stylistically
there's not much difference
between the quotations in
his German and his German.
And you would think that
if he were looking to
identify this or treat this
as the object of his satire,
that he would perhaps in some way,
keep it at arm's length
from his own style,
and the style in "Capital"
most of the time,
it certainly not,
I don't have the sense that it's meant
to be a satirical style.
It seems to be something that he really
tried to make into an effective instrument
for conveying his ideas.
It's a really interesting style,
a style that's very different
from 19th century German academic prose.
I mean, it's marked in various ways by,
as coming from that time
for all sorts of references.
I'm sorry about the
dog, barking dog there.
(laughs)
Pleasures of Zoom.
But it also syntactically
and in terms of word choices,
it's so different from
something like Wonka.
It has this leanness,
the sleekness to it a lot of the time.
And he gives this political economy
that's often really windy and florid
and gives it a kind of
leanness and tautness
that it doesn't have,
doesn't necessarily deserve.
And so, I'm wondering how that
connects with this argument
about the satirical agenda in "Capital."
- Well, that's an extremely good question.
He's doing a couple of things at once.
It's not as straightforward satire.
And we know from the 1840s
that he could write
straightforward ad hominem,
sarcastic satires.
We know that from "The Holy Family"
and "The Poverty of a Philosophy."
And we know that from the
kind of ad hominem stuff
that was going into the manuscripts
that never actually had a title 'til 1902
when they became known
as "The German Ideology."
So we know he was very adapted that
and he's not doing the
same thing in "Capital."
It's a parody.
So it's going to sneak up on the reader.
And so as the text progresses,
you get more and more kind
of sarcastic comments,
particularly in footnotes.
But he's also at the same time
finding their work straightforward
and valuable descriptively.
That is they are working
with the concepts of
ordinary people and ordinary commodity,
traders and merchants,
and ordinary readers of newspapers
like the one that he worked for,
Politics, Trade, and Industry.
And what he is doing is
writing both of these
things at the same time
as indeed the political economists were.
They weren't importing concepts.
They were reframing and
clarifying the concepts
that were already in ordinary usage.
So Marx is quite onboard with that
because he's looking at
this clarified version
of what actually goes on in
commodity producing a society.
In a sense, he's actually buying into
the puzzle about profit
and he's just coming up with
a new concept and a solution
that they hadn't come up with.
But he's coming up with a solution
that will pull the rug
out from under them,
and the solution of course
is the exploitation of labor,
the production of surplus value.
And that production as
the foundation of capital
as self-expanding value.
So it's a very difficult book in that way
but you may disagree,
but I always find his
prose very straightforward,
very lean, very taut.
Sometimes, well, extremely
sharp, very combative.
I read all of Marx as
political intervention
from early 1842.
And I mean, all of it.
He could write the kind of
intellectualized journalism
that they had to write at the time
to get into the paper and to
communicate to that audience.
But it's not as difficult
as later 19th century
and certainly 20th
century academic German.
And certainly Marx's prose,
I mean, his best prose work for me
is "The Eighteenth Brumaire
of Louis Bonaparte."
I think it's a fantastic text
and it's the worst translation
in this so-called standard,
ones in true English that there
is done by Daniel De Leon.
So I really enjoyed re-translating that
and it's really explosive
and at the same time colorful.
I think he's a fantastic writer in prose.
If I had to pick something
and my knowledge is not where yours is,
as a kind of model, I would
have picked the Lutheran Bible.
I think that's actually direct stuff.
- Thank you, Terrell.
Thank you, Paul.
We want to, I think there's
a lot of explosive ideas
in what you've been saying
for the past hour or so,
including that all of Marx's writing
is a political intervention,
not a science, for example.
Not metaphysics for another example.
And we can talk about that.
I want to just reiterate what this is
for those who may have come in later.
This is all of our chance to be
TV, radio announcers I guess
and none of us have trained for it.
We should keep in mind here
that we're being subsumed
into the apparatus in a
way that Marx described
and others have described
really eloquently.
And the conditions of
our intellectual work
have really changed a lot.
It is a real pleasure to
see how many people are here
and I wanna welcome you all.
You will notice that we've
jumped into the middle
and a lot of us take for granted
that we've read "Capital" or
know some things about Marx.
Terrell gave it a terrific
introduction to the context
which is often forgotten.
And the arguments we haven't
really touched on today
but he knows them very well
so you're welcome to ask him
questions about value or about labor.
What I'd like to do is
I'd like to give the
students in this seminar
that is a regular college seminar
that goes along with this workshop series
a chance to ask some questions.
Students, if you want to begin.
If you put your questions in the chat,
I will then somehow get to you.
We'll unmute you and you can ask
Professor Carver yourselves.
Then after that we'll open up
and I'll let you know for
the rest of those listening
when you can put your
questions in the chat.
We really want to try to
get to as many as possible.
So for students in the class
I have already one in an email.
This is from, I'm gonna read it
since I have it here from Avery Youngblood
who's a student in the School of Art.
"I wonder what it means to
quote unquote, "shop small,"
a.k.a. support your local businesses
in terms of Marx's views
on private property
and workers versus non-workers."
There we go, right to
the heart of the matter.
- Yes, I agree.
Private property is
the heart of the matter
and that's just something
that Marx puts his finger on
already in 1842.
There was some magic moments
in his early newspaper articles
and this kind of brings me
on to my approach to the text
for the modern reader
which is really to start at the end.
To start in part eight
the so-called primitive
accumulation, chapters 26 to 33,
'cause I think those are the ones
that make the most sense at the moment.
But to make sense of those you have to see
as he explains in those chapters,
the centrality of the developments
of modern private property.
So the story for Marx begins in 1842
with an article on the dispossession
of feudalant peasants from
forestry where they had rights,
subsistence rights to do various things,
pick up firewood or
whatever whilst they needed.
And by actively local ruler,
this was going to be privatized,
turned into a piece of private property,
sold off to an owner who would
subdivide it and make farms.
And they would all be stuck
uncompensated of course.
So it's this process of dispossession
through which modern
private property is created
that sets commodity
production in motion for Marx
such that workers become
available to employers
because they haven't
got anywhere else to go.
And they can't go anywhere else
'cause they're denied access to the land
so therefore they have to work for wages
and go into shops to buy processed food
which is then are produced
for profits are elsewhere
in agribusiness and
packaging and processing.
So this is essentially
what's already going on
in England and Scotland
in the late 18th century
through enclosures and dispossession.
And what is going on in the colonies
and including Ireland,
plantations were set up in Ireland
and Virginia at the same time
where labor costs were
driven as low as possible.
And in the case of imported
forced labor to North America
driven down to zero.
So we know what that is.
So, property is the crucial concept
and Marx's political
intervention is to try
to wake people up to what
is underneath the normality
of clicking on Amazon,
of going into a shop with a chip and pin,
or however they are, wireless connectivity
or an Apple Watch.
And how the local global distinction
is itself a misleading one.
I was reflecting on
this only this morning.
And so I'm thinking about
the supermarket where I go
and I thought, what are
the flags that you see?
Why do I see only Union
Jacks and buy British?
And it tastes better because
like tomatoes tastes better
because they're British.
I mean, please.
You know, if we had little flags all over
all those other packets and labels,
particularly indicating supply chains,
we'd have a much better picture of how,
I'm avoiding the word ideological,
but how mystificatory the local global
consumer's position is
and how it takes away from the actual
brutal hard facts of production
which is really where Marx is starting.
- Terrell, are you saying,
if I can just follow up,
that the local is a fiction
and that really the supply
chains can't be avoided
when producing something like that?
Or that the local is such a small fraction
of the world economy that
it's inconsequential?
- It's not a fiction, it's real.
It's real because people use the words
and they believe in the words,
and they organize their
lives around these words.
But it's mystificatory
and this is going straight
from Marx's playbook "Capital,"
a section on fetishism of commodities,
chapter one, section four.
I believe you can read
the real stuff there
where he describes how economics
and the political economy
of his day and ours
is a political project to
ensure that we see something is
and don't reflect on others.
So it will hit, I don't know,
The Huffington Post and
the news sites occasionally
that Apple workers in Shenzhen
have terrible working conditions.
Well, what should we think about that?
And what Marx is providing
or trying to provide
is a framework through
which to understand that
and to form a judgment.
And he makes very clear
with sarcastic comments
and eventually a thinly
disguised programmatic one
in chapter 27 I think
where he's coming from and
what he thinks the solution is.
But it's got to get past the censor
and we all have issues with that.
- Thank you.
I have two further questions
from students in the seminar
starting with Bilal who
asks Professor Carver,
well, let's see if Bilal can unmute.
Can we unmute Bilal, let
him speak for himself?
This may require some technical magic.
- [Yasmin] Yeah, Paul,
before we get started,
there's a couple of questions
above if you scroll up.
So there's one from a Jonas
and then a Ryan Ofman.
So Jonas Kilga also had a question above.
- Good.
Let's since I am going backwards,
let's stick with Bilal for the first,
if you can unmute him.
- [Yasmin] Okay.
- [Paul] Then we'll just go
backwards through the list.
Thank you.
- Right.
Thank you, Professor Carver.
I had a question.
From your text you'd mentioned
other contemporary texts
that share the title "Capital"
and have a very similar approach.
And you mentioned the Piketty's
"Capital in The Twenty-First Century."
There are some...
I mean, I saw similarities between
Piketty's critique of capitalism
and Marx's "Capital" itself
but the methods are quite different.
It's not a really a
traditional Marxist approach.
So I was wondering how Marx would react,
his findings about inequality
in the 21st century
and the world that he describes.
- Well, I think Marx would
definitely buy the book
and buy the next book about
ideology and capitalism
which essentially says what I've just said
in the previous answer.
That is a lot of effort goes
into helping us see things
one way rather than another.
And not connecting the dots you might say
so I see Piketty in both books
as trying to connect up the dots
that Marx said we're there
but doing it with modern methods
and particularly with
an absolute avalanche
of empirical examples, data
statistics, and all of that,
I think Marx was trying
to get his hands on that
but of course in 1867
statistics data collection
really hardly exist.
So I think one instructive
thing in reading a text
from out of the past like this
is to spend some time
trying to think about
and to find out about what sources
and what knowledge of was
even potentially available
to the person at that time.
If you think about what Marx says
about China and India for instance,
how could he have known much of anything
and in terms of the sources
that he did have available?
What in fact were they?
This is still very early days in terms of
even collecting data that
calls itself economic
about European countries.
And for as far as trying to understand
societies outside Europe.
I mean, this is really early days also.
So there just actually
isn't very much there.
I mean, even if,
I remember Darwin is only 1859
and that's the origin of species
is built on geological
knowledge from the 1830s, 1840s
on which which was not accepted.
I mean, Darwin was persecuted
and had endless problems
for questioning the Bible.
So if you look at the 1840s and ask,
well, what could Marx possibly have known
about the Roman Empire
or the ancient world,
or the ancient world
outside the Roman Empire?
You're not looking at very much
and quite a lot of it is gonna be located
in around the Bible,
they're certainly filtered through that.
So I think one has to bear
all those things in mind
but I think he'd be delighted
with Piketty's books.
I think they're great.
- Can I follow up?
Bilal, thank you very much.
This is a little bit more
of a provocation I think
but Piketty in the first
book called "Capital"
focuses on inequality
and his solution is something like
redistribution through taxation.
Do you think if Marx had the statistics
that he would come down,
he would have been a liberal?
- Well, I think there's little difference
between Marx and liberals to start with
but there is some difference.
So as I said, Marx is fully on board
with popular sovereignty
and universal male suffrage,
which was actually in the
French Constitution of 1793.
They just didn't put it into practice.
And as I say it was first
put into practice in 1848.
So remember, it's commonly said Marx is
very influenced by the
French revolutionaries
but he's very close to the
French revolution of 1830
which is the constitutional monarchy.
I mean, that's in his lifetime.
So I think again, we need to need to get
close to where these people actually are
to understand what it is
that they're thinking about.
And the suffrage is so
somewhat widened at that point.
So Marx does face a political
dilemma from the beginning
because as early as 1842
he's onto the private property thing
and the suffering of the peasants.
So on the one hand,
the liberal businessman would
like to get the peasants
into the shops with money
and the government doesn't really
want them into the factories
because they don't really want factories.
And the charity angle isn't working out,
so what the businessmen
are really upset about
is the town filling up with beggars.
This is going to be really annoying
for people who want to shop.
So that's why they want Friedrich List
to come in and help
the Prussian government
sort themselves out.
But they don't want too much
messing with private property
or too much redistribution.
They just like some economic
organization of wage labor
which they think would
be quite beneficial.
And if it requires dispossession
that's quite okay with them.
And actually it's quite
okay with Marx at that point
since he's got to have allies.
Those who believe in the
collective ownership of property
rather than the ownership
of private property,
particularly in the means
of production such as land,
there's going to be a tension there,
so he's got to keep that kind of quiet.
And Moses Hess was involved with this,
everybody was looking for a solution.
So these people have got to work together
and that's what Marx did in the Rhineland,
it's what he did in Paris,
it's what he did in Brussels.
There weren't enough socialists around
and they weren't collected enough
on what on earth they meant
by collective ownership of property
anyway to make much of a case.
So they're still working that out.
They're just trying to
get rid of reactionary
religious, fanatic, maniac,
authoritarian rulers who can
be really, really annoying,
and really frustrating
and don't want anybody
to vote for anything.
And even in the French Republic,
hardly anybody voted for anything anyway.
So their first angle was democracy.
And if you look to the end
of "The Communist Manifesto,"
part four, there's a list of demands
all of which are basically liberal demands
including nationalization of the banks
and provision of work for the disabled
and provision of work for everybody.
And free public education
which is unknown at the time
and all of those other kinds of things.
Not a word about the
abolition of private property,
it's a strictly redistribution.
And if you look at the
fly-posted 17 demands
of the communist party
which Marx and Engels
actually got fly-posted around
in the German states as
opposed to the manifesto
which went no where except
the Prussian Police archives.
the fly-posting, which they signed
which got Engels into terrible
trouble in his hometown
is a straightforward
list of those demands,
all of which are impeccably liberal.
So you've got to have allies.
I mean, Marx was politically astute.
He was making political intervention.
So I don't think there's a problem there.
Liberals may have felt there was a problem
and they were nervous.
- Thanks. Thank you very much.
I want to turn to Ryan Ofman.
Can we unmute Ryan for his question?
- [Ryan] Hello? Hello?
- [Paul] Hi, Ryan. We hear you.
- [Ryan] Awesome.
So my other question was kind of
on your description of Marx's
relationship with science.
I think there was a slide on it earlier.
And I very much agree that
when I'm reading his descriptions
I think it's a very, very like cynical
view of how science works
and that very well might be the case.
Do you think it's more of a general,
something about the nature of science
that Marx thinks is fundamentally going
to kind of boil down to capitalism
or is it more about the
specific institutions
that Marx was kind of raised on?
Like I'm sure the university he was at
had a quite demanding and quite specific
way of dealing with science.
- Thank you. Great question.
The university he went to
you had no science at all.
So in the sense that we have it,
it was a traditional
unreformed university.
So I would go back to
the educational milieu
of the 1820, 1830s
and this is continuous to and
beyond the '48 revolutions
and it's quite an intellectual
revolution led from Berlin,
and from the Prussian
royal university there
and it's not from their
traditional universities like bond.
(speaks in foreign language)
In the German at the time.
This is a rigorous study of anything.
I mean, Hegel's system
building on any subject
whether metaphysics or nature
or logic was (speaks in foreign language)
because it was rigorous.
And indeed modern science
accepts the same thing,
it's supposed to be rigorous and logical
in the first instance.
So what you get from the
more sort of Anglocentric
and later reformed German universities
is conception of science that accepts
a physical materialism
which can only really get to
be respectable after Darwin
and people have got away with
a kind of separation in metaphysical terms
between faith and the material world.
And as that is becoming more
technologically successful,
engineering and early
physical and material science
were all the same thing anyway,
electricity, physics,
and all of that stuff.
If you go back through the
history of science and technology,
they're all the same thing from about
the 1760s, 1780s onwards.
So, these things all have to have a use
and the experimentation
has to be paid for.
And it's often quite difficult to do.
I would approach this
very much historically
and try to make sure that
we're not projecting a kind of
scientific materialism,
matter in motion and mathematical methods
from the 1870s and 1880s and onwards
back onto something
that really didn't exist
anywhere very much and in Marx's time.
So, I'll just pull the 1844
manuscripts out of a hat here.
This is another sort of
editorial kind of geeky point.
These are kind of ripped
out of Marx's notebooks
and turned into a manuscript
work in the 1920s.
But even so, you can see
that he actually just says
that in so far as we have
(speaks in foreign language),
study of the material world,
it's driven by and goes into
technologies of ordinary life.
And that's what industry is.
Marx is very fixated on technologies
and therefore, economics of ordinary life
in whatever stage of
society we're looking at.
So it quite specifically says
that his overall outlook
which is historical all the way down,
includes all of previous
forms and stages if you like
or formations of society
in terms of the way
that people interacted together
to get along in the material world.
It just takes different
forms at different times
but he's quite happy.
And this is actually in "Capital"
with the stone age,
bronze age and iron age
and that actually gets a footnote,
and that was a new thing
in the 1860s series.
Quite interested in stone age technologies
and might sound odd to
call this stone age science
but in terms of being
rigorous and logical,
and apparently not doing what
baboons or apes do when
they use simple tools.
I mean, he's definitely onto something.
- [Ryan] Thank you.
- Thanks, Ryan.
We have one more student with a question.
Can we go to Jonas Kilga
- [Jonas] Hi.
Can everyone hear me?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- [Jonas] Awesome. Thank you.
So you mentioned censorship
a lot in your talk
and in the text that you sent out,
you also said he published "Das Kapital"
in handbook originally
because the censors were more lenient.
And I think when you're reading Marx,
it is quite a peculiar language
and maybe that's just 1860s German.
But knowing about the censorship
or that he had to grapple with it,
I was wondering concretely how "Capital"
was affected by censorship
if there are any,
if there's textual
evidence to look out for
where you can sense that
Marx was sort of trying to
write around certain stipulations
put in place by censors.
- Well, I think there's
an awful lot of that.
I mean, you have to put
yourself in the mind
of the censor of the time
and then in Marx's minds
to try to figure out
what he's not writing.
But that's quite a lot of
quotation from published sources,
some of which is quite
critical of capitalism.
So that's a move.
I mean, none of these moves are guaranteed
to get around the censor.
I was particularly struck
in reading part eight again
that we get to an apocalyptic
moments of capitalist collapse
where he describes the
proletariat overthrowing
the regime of private property,
and says it's the
negation of the negation.
Well, this is sort of pounced on in the
post-1920 world of Marx reception
showing that he's still valued Hegel.
I think this is really a way
of getting around the censorship
by not saying too much about this
volcanic change in the social
order that he's envisioning,
and quickly covering it up
with a kind of meaningless
philosophical phrase
that doesn't say much of anything
and then moving swiftly on.
All of this,
of course only comes in part eight
by which time you assume the
censor has got very bored.
So, censors were known to
be kind of the beginning
and a bit of the end
and kind of flip through
'cause they're on a paycheck,
they have books to go through.
So Marx was pretty successful with that
and it's word of mouth where
you go for your publishers.
And there's a lot of
that in correspondence
about where to go and who
will put up the money for it,
and how to get the money,
whether you split the
cost with the publisher,
and how much risk the
publisher's going to take,
and all that kind of stuff.
But publication was not
free and it was censored,
and as I point out,
they were lucky to get through
the Russian censorship.
Now, at least again, in a sense
on the kind of foreign angle,
there's an awful lot of
foreign writers in there
so we don't have to worry very much.
And capitalism was a wholly foreign idea
and Russia in the early
1870s, it was so new,
the censor hadn't really heard of it,
didn't know what to do with it.
It seemed it was of no interest
in a really autocratic, medieval,
obsessive feudal satire.
So then it was kind of a
tedious work on a subject
nobody knows anything about.
So you kind of have to rely
on censorial ignorance.
It's not as well developed as censorship
has been in other places.
- Thanks, Terrell.
I'm sure all the Hegelians in the audience
will have been interested.
(Terrell laughs)
Hegel speak in the book was an attempt
to get around the censors.
I would like to open up
the floor for questions
from all the spectators now.
We have some in the chat.
I wonder if we can
actually unmute the folks
and have them ask their questions.
Let's try.
Yasmin if you're on,
we have a question from Sara Wexler.
I think we can find
Sara Wexler and unmute.
- [Yasmin] Yes, Sara, you should
be able to unmute herself.
- [Sara] Hello?
- Hi. We hear you.
- [Sara] Okay. Yeah.
I recently read William Clare
Robert's book "Marx's Inferno"
and he's also kind of trying to
politically contextualize "Capital."
And so I was just wondering
if what you thought about his take that
Marx is sort of advocating
for some sort of
republicanism when he's writing "Capital."
- Well, I thoroughly recommend the book.
There are not a whole lot of books
on this subject I recommend
but that's clearly one.
I think his take on the political
intervention is wonderful.
It's quite clever.
He says it's written within the context
of the International
Workingmen's Association
to which ladies were admitted.
And that it's really
getting it Proudhonist
although Proudhon is hardly
mentioned in the text.
So I think that's a little
bit of the parody satire.
Angle Marx had already done
a sort of straight up
satirical attack on Proudhon
so there's not too much
point doing it again.
Better just to show what he wanted to show
which is that he was very much
better at it than Proudhon.
And instead of riling the Proudhonians
he would kind of pull a fast one on them.
So I think Will is
absolutely right about that.
I'm less onboard with
the republicanism thing.
Quite a lot of people thought that was
a little bit unnecessary or projected.
I'm more inclined to stick with
popular sovereignty and liberalism,
although they are part
of the same dialogue.
So I don't go all the way
with Will on that one.
I think the Dante's "Inferno"
thing is quite clever.
It shows an awful lot of really geeky,
nerdy grad student research.
He taught himself the
whole world of Dante ana
in order to do this,
so it's an awesome thing to take on board.
For me it didn't actually add that much
to my reading of "Capital"
to see it passed out
as a kind of tribute to Dante.
It's also been passed out
as a kind of tribute to Hegel's logic.
I think it's got a logic of its own.
One of the points I make in the text
is that where is "Capital"
is actually quite a good question
because it's a project I think from 1842
and from late 1843 when he reads Engels'
"Outlines of A Critique
of Political Economy"
and just goes electric.
He then sketches out a plan for a critique
of political economy
and spends the rest of his life on that.
And we've got a lot of manuscript build up
and reading notes and notebooks
that lead up to this.
And we've got the intense
activity 1857 onwards
that got published
eventually as grid reserve.
We've got drafts of "Capital, Volume I"
and we've got his
rewrites and new additions
in the French translation of it.
And so therefore "Capital One"
is more like a taster volume or a snapshot
and we know he was kind
of pressured as usual
by family and friends
to get something out.
So, it's not thrown together
but it's he had to make a stop with it
and decide what was gonna be
in it as a single volume work.
There's also a bit of a health warning
on Volumes II and III.
Volume III is from manuscripts
that predate Volume I.
Volume II is in a very rough state
and Engels' editor saying is
subject to a lot of critique.
Not all of it unsympathetic.
Editors have a hard job when authors
don't make up their mind and
say contradictory things.
And I think that's a big clue about Marx.
He was really curious
and really exploratory
and was, didn't feel obliged
to have a dogmatic view
unless he really thought about it.
And then I don't think he particularly
wanted to be dogmatic.
- And said in a letter
that he wasn't a Marxist.
- Well now I'll correct
you if I may on that.
Engels' reports in two letters
that he heard Marx say it
two different ways in French.
Got it?
- Got it.
Let's turn to some other questions.
I'm gonna go through the chat now.
So let's see if we can unmute.
- [Participant] Hi. Can everyone hear me?
- Yeah.
- Absolutely.
- [Paul] Okay.
- [Participant] Okay, so
this is a question about
the labor theory of value.
I was wondering what you think
about the labor theory of value
and whether it has some
grain of truth to it today.
- Almost everything has a grain of truth
and I certainly think that.
I think we have to go
back to political economy
and as I've said, the puzzle
that they were solving at the time,
and the way that they chose
labor as a common factor.
And they were presenting
a puzzle about profit
and solving it or trying to solve it
in very Aristotelian terms.
So it's a very classical problem
they're trying to solve with tools
of moralizing philosophy
which is somewhat connected
with the empirical world.
That is they took human labor
to be an empirical kind of object.
That works in that kind
of neo-Aristotelian
framework as far as it goes, excuse me.
There's a couple of chapters
in "The Postmodern Marx"
that show how it works in that context.
And why if you shift your
ground to modern physics
or a more post-Aristotelian, materialist,
physical understanding of the world
based on physics and chemistry,
it really doesn't work well at all.
Even just empirically, it's not clear
that there's something that
we can specify or define
as labor in the human
context as opposed to leisure
though people talk as if there is.
We can define things like
wage work and employment,
ask anybody in a tax
office what employment is
and they will tell you,
but they probably won't
tell you what work is
or what labor is.
It's a convenience sort of label.
One student said, well, what about donkeys
and animals who work?
We have a lot of hardworking
animals around the world.
Why are they not since they're doing
the same kinds of things
that humans are doing?
We've got animals that are
working for us biologically now.
And in modern terms, I don't think
there are very good
answers to those questions.
Alternatively, we can
turn it around and say,
well, let's look at
the world of production
from the point of view of the human being
and what human beings are required to do
because they can't subside,
they can't subsist otherwise.
And then I think we're much more on board
with the theory of exploitation
which is really where Marx's
concept of labor power
and surplus value is going.
He's developing a concept of exploitation.
There are various ways you can construct
empirical proxies for this
and there's quite a lot
of mileage in doing that.
Marxist economists have done
that in very respectable work
which gets a very good audience.
It gets ignored because
it doesn't start out
with the concepts and the methods
that more Orthodox economists
are used to working with.
I think Piketty has a nice
point of compromise there.
He's quite interested in human beings
and the things that they're required to do
within the productive set up
that capitalism causes
them to be enmeshed in
whether they like it or not,
and some of them like it
and some of them don't.
And so people change their views about it
as life goes along,
you may think it's great
when you're employed
and not when you're not.
So there's all those things going on.
I quite liked David Harvey's approach
which is really to zoom
in at Volume II stage
and look at capitalist flows,
and in a sense just kind of put the whole
labor value thing on the back burner
and look at capital flows
and then come back around
to let's look at workers,
and their kinds of conditions.
So there are lots of
things to be done with.
I think it is quite difficult
to pick up "Capital, Volume
I" and start on page one
and figure out what is going on,
and why things are
problematic and puzzling,
and what the concepts mean
and what they don't mean
given what's happened in the
180 years or so afterwards.
- And we don't wanna give
people too much of a fright
so that they don't try it.
(Terrell laughs)
Your own quote I do think
should come back in here.
- Okay.
- It's worth it as all
difficult things are
and since we have to live under capital,
it can't be worse than that.
(Terrell laughs)
Wanna go now to a question
that was posed at a little
while ago by Martin Bradbury.
I wonder if we can unmute Martin
if he's still in the.
- [Martin] Hello?
- [Paul] Hi, Martin.
- [Martin] Hello.
So, my question is about the relationship
between Hegel and Marx.
Hegel's already been mentioned.
And from some of my
readings of (indistinct)
from the Frankfurt School,
so like a dorm, they
wouldn't know if he was.
I've come to sort of
understand Marx's project
as basically an attempt
to radicalize Hegel.
There's a section in the
"Economic and Philosophic Manuscripts
of course where this dedicated in time
to criticizing Hegel.
There's a famous quote from Marx
where he talks about how when he was
writing the (indistinct)
he happen to leave through Hegel again.
So, this is something that
keeps coming up for it,
the history of Marxism.
But it's also being counted
of course by other schools,
the one that comes to mind spaces
are the analytical Marxists.
When we enable Marxist
we therefore call that Hegelian
speculative philosophy.
So my question really is
to what extent is this idea that
Marx was trying to radicalize Hegel,
something that Marx would
probably have agreed with?
Or is it this notion that's been
brought into it by Marx's interpreters
like Malki with certain
people that came afterwards.
- Well, thank you very
much for that question.
It's all of those things.
So if we go back to the beginning,
who was Hegel in the first place?
Hegel was an academic philosopher.
He published a lot to the
German speaking audience.
He was famous as a critic of Kant.
He wrote a philosophical system
which was going to make
(speaks in foreign language)
a rigorous sense of
everything that ever was
and will be everything you could possibly
want to know about.
He was famous in his
own time, much admired.
His disciples collected his writings
and filled out his collected
works in the 1830s.
And he was, as we say in Britain,
by the 1830s, a national treasure.
He had become the East
Prussian Philosopher of Choice.
He was there in the public view.
Since the public was not
allowed to have a view
about very much and
there wasn't even really
supposed to be a public
interested in politics
because he was so famous
and so famously ambiguous,
and because he covered everything
including history and politics,
he was away in to the
politics of the time.
He was the politics of the time
in that you could discuss
it in a coded form
by talking about him.
So, there was no need to radicalize him.
He was already radicalized by the 1830s
and he was already
conservativized by the 1830s.
This debate was already raging
and he was blamed in the
culture war of the time
for destroying Christian faith
and preaching atheism.
But also defending the Prussian state
and Orthodox confessional Christianity.
So this shows you the
advantages of ambiguity
and also the advantages of being dead,
and of being a national treasure.
So he was the national philosopher
and how to read and understand him,
particularly what he says about the,
on political subjects and
the philosophy of right is
political philosophy,
philosophy of the state
and society, and the family,
he's covered all those things.
What you think he's saying
is itself a political issue
and this is debated and published on
in the Alternative Press
and in the official press,
and professors are appointed by the state
and kicked out by the state
to take the right view on
this philosophical subject.
The 20th century reception
from the 1920s onwards,
doesn't quite see this.
The people who do it already
academic philosophers
and are not reading the
politics of the time
though coming out Marx
making him as a philosopher
which was already going on in the 1880s.
Rather weirdly, Engels of course,
wanted to make him a
materialist philosopher
and therefore onboard
with the physical science of that time.
And a Hegelian systematizing philosopher
to keep him in the German mainstream
doing both of these at the same time
in his works of the 1880s
when he revisits the 1840s
and this of course not
really very accurate
40 years on in his recollections.
So this is a complicated story
of overlapping receptions.
One can make Marx into a Hegelian.
I think it's really part of
the politics of the 1920s
where people are trying to read Marx
outside of the Orthodox Marxist
materialist framework
of deterministic laws.
They're picking up on
Hegel whom they assume
can only be read in an idealist way.
They don't quite want to say
that Marx is an idealist.
He's just a Hegelian.
They've pick up on the
young Hegelian discourse
which they can find in the Marx archive,
and then do some research on
which had been leftover and ignored.
Engels doesn't really revive it.
And actually nobody revives it
because everybody is onboard
with materialist science
until the 1920s
and we get this Hegel revival
both in Weimar, Germany and in France.
So some of the most influential
French Hegelian reception of Marx
comes in lectures actually
given at the Sorbonne
So I give them some credits in that
they're reading Marx
outside the materialist
Orthodox deterministic framework.
On the other hand, I think they mistake
where those works and texts
are actually coming from.
And it kind of depoliticized it
as it makes what I think
is actually an exciting
political intervention.
- We have four questions in the chat.
I think I'm going to count the forth
from Marco Lata as pretty well answered.
He or they ask whether
dialectics and critique
were terms in common use
given what you've said about Hegel
and the milieu in which Marx was writing.
I think it's pretty clear that they were
but Marco if you have more
specific questions about that,
you can certainly write
Professor Carver or myself.
Then let's go to Isaac Kirk-Davidoff
if he's still in the room.
- [Isaac] Yeah.
Well, hi.
Professor Carver, I
just wanted to know that
like there's so much imagery in "Capital."
There's like tables, dancing,
there's vampires he references,
like Robinson Crusoe,
and what's my favorite
footnote of "Capital."
I just wanna know what you
make of all the imagery,
is this like reaching to describe things
that like political economy
doesn't have a language for,
that Marx doesn't have a language for?
Or is it more like just
for the sake of the reader?
Like what do you make of all this imagery?
- Well, I think that's a
really interesting question
and my story on this is
that in the early 1980s
I gave a word by word
chapter by chapter class
with someone else's
seminar class on capital
and I gave it several years running.
And so I've got a little bit daydreamy
going through the book,
chapter one for the Nth time.
So I got out my little yellow highlighter
and just started highlighting the images
'cause I was interested
in metaphor at the time.
And I began to realize that there's
a whole world of occult imagery there
some of which is biblical from Revelation
and some of which just
arrives from the occults
like the tables turning,
there's famously the
vampires, there's werewolves.
So, I've got up my
highlighter and I made a list.
And I read a short article
which was published in the then
Times Literary Supplements.
And it's one of the chapters
in "The Postmodern Marx"
which you might enjoy.
And the further answer is I thought, well,
what is all this doing though?
That's not just to entertain us.
There must be some kind of thread.
So, I think the threads goes like this,
it's a classic kind of
enlightenment argument
against ignorance and superstition.
And it's coded against religion in general
and it does actually tie
into political economy.
So the argument goes like this.
Okay, enlightenment post-Hegelian
liberals of the time,
those who've read David Friedrich Strauss
on the life of Jesus
and don't buy the literal truth
of the Christian confessional anymore.
We know you're all past that.
Look, what I'm showing you is that
the world of commodity production
which we're looking at
through empirical testimony
and through works of political economy
is just as mystificatory
and just as performative
as we might say these days.
That is commodities are, as
Marx says, really strange.
You just think there's something
in a shop with a price tag.
But let's try to think
about them as really weird.
How is it that they have a price on them?
What does price mean?
He says, "Price is often language
that commodities speak to each other?"
This is getting really
strange and stranger.
How is it that we have markets
with forces moving by themselves
which we have created
that control our lives
in which we bow down and worship.
This is the fetishism of commodities.
Well, fetishism at the
time wasn't (indistinct)
It was the projection of human
qualities onto stone idols
such that they command
the humans will seem to
and the humans believe
that the stone idols
have magical powers and money,
and monetized behavior,
and all the things that
neoliberals complain about,
and all the boxes we have
to take on the tax forms.
So just all instances of being
trapped within this performative,
ritualistic world of commodity concepts
that we all believe in because we have to.
But hey, look, historically,
this was made up historically.
There was a time when
we didn't have money,
we didn't have commodities.
We didn't have capital.
We got on, we traded
things, we produced things.
Let's not go back there
but then let's realize that
commodity, production, and capitalism
don't have to be here forever.
So there's a historical
argument going along now
along with an intellectual argument,
which is that, okay, woke up liberals,
you don't believe in this
religious stuff anymore.
Apply the same argument
to the commodity stuff.
It's just as weird as
believing in the incarnation
and the Holy Spirit and
the Immaculate Conception.
It's just it's got dressed
up as political economy
or economics and we don't
have to bow down and worship
once we realize it's a collection of
human concepts that we act out.
So there is a substantive way
that some people could have recognized
and it's part of the satire.
It's just not because it works both ways.
I mean, it's outlandish to say
that capitalists are werewolves
and capitalism is a vampire
sucking the blood of the workers.
But there's loads of
empirical stuff put in there
to show exactly that
and Marx quotes horrifying stuff
by the time you get to part eight
about what happens in the
Indian so-called mutiny.
And other things like that from the maths,
from the writing sort of colonialists
and anti-colonialists themselves.
So the whole thing is very joined up,
you just have to get all the
way through to part eight,
to see how it works where
horror meets horror.
- You have two more questions.
I'm mindful of the time.
People on the East Coast
want to get to dinner
and people in the UK want to get to bed.
So let me just give you a summary
of the last two questions.
One is from Ali Ecta who's
a student in the seminar
and this follows up on the
last things you were saying.
What do you think about
the theological rhetoric
in "Capital" that Marx occasionally uses
like quoting Jesus, "They
know not what they do."
"Is this a satire," he asks,
"or is this putting himself
into a messianic position?"
And the last question is
going back to what you said
about "The Communist Manifesto."
Isn't it unfair to characterize
the demands of the manifesto as liberal
given the politics of the time?
It was opposed by liberals as you said.
Wouldn't it be more likely to think of it,
I guess he means as communist
or at least supporting
the worker's struggle?
- Okay, I think anything from...
Anything about their purports
to come from religion
that's said by Marx with a straight face
is totally satirical.
He arrived at atheism very early on
and this put him on the
radical edge of everybody.
You could be seriously persecuted.
You couldn't get a job.
You couldn't do anything, much of anything
as an atheist if word
got around about you.
So, that is all totally satirical.
It belongs to the same thing as putting
and this is a powerful argument.
I mean the whole business
of economic production
under capitalism in the
same box as religious faith
seems to be a serious category mistake.
We're used to keeping
them in separate boxes.
Oh well, I go to the shops
but then I have my faith elsewhere.
Marx is saying, well look,
it's the same kind of
socially made up phenomenon.
And so, I mean Marx went the whole way
with Feuerbach and Strauss
which is that religion generally
and Christianity of course
as part of that is a projection of
human ideas, concepts, and values
on to things that are either
stone idols or don't exist,
or are truths that
supposedly come from books,
all of which require human interpreters
in authority structures.
So, I mean, that's deeply satirical.
What's interesting is how
learned he was on Christianity
and Bible study.
I mean, he really knew it off completely
and he's completely expert with it.
And it's great language
and it's another reason why
I think the Lutheran Bible is
really the key to his prayers.
The other question about liberalism,
I think we have to go back again
to the politics of the time
when being liberal,
the German-speaking state
wasn't being liberal,
it was being treasonous.
You could be put in jail for
advocating popular sovereignty,
for advocating constitutionalism.
It was horrendous
and remember that the
French Revolution of 1830
is easily living memory.
I mean risk their own lifetimes.
I mean the rulers East of
the Rhine are terrified
that's going to happen to them.
The mob are going to come and get them,
demand more votes from more people.
And rather unfortunately for them
Louis-Philippe sort of ran off.
Didn't defend his throne,
he ran off to Twickenham in London
and set up his kingdom in exile.
And you've got to be
pals with Queen Victoria.
They were really terrified of this.
And so to come back with our idea
that we're all in a system where
liberalism is part of the mainstream,
the opposite is communism,
really mistakes, the politics
of the period quite badly.
Those demands are revolutionary demands
for constitutionalism.
And those people who signed
those demands got put on trial
and Marx argued his way
out of a jury conviction
and got tried in absentia.
And some of these people went to prison
and they went into exile.
And they didn't all go to nice places even
those nicest Soho in London
which wasn't very nice.
- This is a way to just pause
a much longer discussion
about Marx and his radicality.
You've given us a really
radical reading I think,
and a lot to think about.
I wanna thank you very much
for your time and your effort,
and all your work over many years
to be able to sum things
up so beautifully for us.
- Thank you.
It's been an absolute delight.
I've enjoyed the questions
obviously very considerably.
I'm tempted to go back to share a screen
and show you the book with
the volcano on the front.
That was actually my idea in that
the publishers wanted nature on the cover.
And I thought, well, nature,
I looked at the covers
which were all gardens,
which was I thought,
well, that isn't gonna do.
What garden is Marx gonna evoke.
So I thought, well, let's go for metaphor.
So I thought about the great wave,
a tidal wave, a tsunami,
some sort of unstoppable force.
And the designers came back
and they said, "Well,
here's some Great Waves
including Hiroshige,"
who's out of copyright.
And they said, "But it
does make it look like
a surfing book."
And they said, "Well,
how about volcanoes?"
And I said, "Hey, that's a great idea."
So they came up with a volcano
and a few weeks later,
I happened to be reading Marx's
"Speech to The People's Paper
which is a very early
work written in English
I think not entirely by him.
He actually talks about
the forthcoming year,
you know, the proletariat
as a volcanic eruption.
- We hope that-
- The book channel this Marx.
I mean, that's obvious.
Anyway, thank you very much.
It's been delightful.
- Thank you, Terrell.
Given the amount of people
who were in the audience,
it seems like the magma is getting hot.
I want to say to everyone before they go
that this series so beautifully kicked off
by Professor Carver is
gonna go on next week.
Marcello Musto, Musto from York
University is gonna be here.
We will have William Clare Roberts
talking about the literary
dimensions of the text.
We have people talking
about reproductive labor,
about racial capital,
about the economic questions.
So I hope you tune back in
for the rest of the series.
Thanks very much.
- Thank you.